la bande originale du seigneur des
anneaux est épique
mes deux frères de montréal veulent
pousser la note encore plus en projetant
le film accompagné de deux cent
cinquante chanteurs et musiciens sur
scène
chaque fois qu'on fait une production on
invite des gens nous disent tout et on
est les plus jeunes à personne au monde
mais qui sont très contents de
travailler depuis deux ans ses deux
frères jumeaux de 22 ans et leur ami du
primaire produisent des ciné concerts et
ça fonctionne ils ont vendu près de 6000
billets pour leurs deux concerts
présentés en fin de semaine à la salle
wilfrid pelletier
j'avais déjà cette expérience j'avais
travaillé beaucoup d' avec d'autres
tournées avec un brin bocelli au centre
bell game of thrones est un aimant donc
j'étais déjà dans ce milieu ils ont
recruté dans leur équipe denis chabot
qui évoluent sur la scène musicale
depuis plusieurs années sont arrivés
avec un projet complètement monte bien
structuré bien finances il n'y avait pas
d'erreur moi j'étais je n'ai pas de mots
pour dire comment c'était impressionnant
de voir trois jeunes extrêmement
intelligent mais très ouverts aussi
depuis ils produisent des ciné concerts
pour accompagner certaines des plus
grands ce méga production hollywoodienne
la guerre des étoiles
fantasia
ou encore titanic
[Musique]
la magie du cinéma opère souvent grâce à
la puissance de la musique d'orchestre
ça permet de comprendre que la musique
et le cinéma savent se fait pas tout
seul il ya du travail derrière sow et on
se le cache pas la musique de i'm watch
ou si elles n'existaient pas est-ce que
la trilogie du seigneur des anneaux ce
cas le chef-d'oeuvre qu'on connaît ça
participe au culte du film avant ottawa
le 6 mars
montréal vibrera en fin de semaine au
son des airs du mordor et de la terre du
milieu
et si nabi alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal